>> Will: THE FIFTH INSTALLMENT
OF THE TWITTER FILES REVEALING
THE LENGTHS THE COMPANY WENT TO
BAR PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM THE
PLATFORM.
>> BARI WEISS TWEETING AFTER
JANUARY 6TH TWITTER DEMAND BAN
TRUMP.
A LOT OF EMPLOYEE ADVOCACY
HAPPENING SAID ONE TWITTER
EMPLOYEE.
THERE WAS SOME PUSHBACK.
AT LEAST A LITTLE PUSHBACK ONE
EMPLOYEE WROTE ON JANUARY 7TH
MAYBE BECAUSE I'M FROM CHINA BUT
I DEEPLY UNDERSTAND HOW
CENSORSHIP CAN DESTROY THE
PUBLIC CONVERSATION.
JOINING US NOW IS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR TAMMY BRUCE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> Will: WHAT'S YOUR BIGGEST
TAKE AWAY FROM TWITTER FILES 5.
>> IT'S WHAT WE WOULD HAVE
EXPECTED.
IT'S NICE TO HAVE PROOF.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE IT SHOWN TO
US.
I WOULD CAUTION AND I THINK THIS
IS A LARGER STORY.
THIS ISN'T REALLY -- AND TRUMP
ALWAYS SAID THIS FROM THE
BEGINNING, THAT NONE OF THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT HIM.
THAT THIS IS THE EXPOSURE OF
SOMETHING MUCH LARGER.
THAT HE IS ONE ASPECT.
AND WHAT HE REPRESENTS, OF
COURSE, IS RECOGNIZING THE
FORGOTTEN MAN AND WOMAN, VOICING
OPPOSITION TO THINGS.
NEW IDEAS AND ALL OF THAT THE
LARGER STORY HERE IS, OF COURSE,
THE COLLUSION, APPARENTLY WITH
GOVERNMENT.
AND TWITTER TO DO.
THIS THIS IS ONE ENTITY.
WE ALSO HAVE GOOGLE.
WE HAVE FACEBOOK.
WE HAVE OTHER, YOU KNOW,
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE COUNTRY.
THIS SHOWS US THE EASE WITH
WHICH THEY DID THIS AND THE
COMFORT.
AND THE KIND OF THE AUTOMATIC
WILLINGNESS TO DO IT IS THAT
THIS IS HOW THEY OPERATE.
THIS IS A SIGN THAT THE LEFT'S
PRIMARY FOCUS IS TO SHUT PEOPLE
UP.
IS TO SHUT DOWN THE
CONVERSATION.
BECAUSE I THINK THEY KNOW THAT'S
THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN WIN.
BUT, ALSO, IT IS BECAUSE THESE
WHAT THEY HAVE BECOME USED TO.
>> AND, FOR GENERATIONS, I WOULD
ARGUE, THROUGH LEGACY MEDIA AND
OTHER DYNAMICS WHICH IS HARDER
FOR US TO UNDERSTAND OR SEE, YOU
WE SUDDENLY SAW IT AND I THINK
THAT'S THE LARGER BIG ISSUE.
NOT PEOPLE SHOULDN'T THINK THIS
IS JUST ABOUT TWITTER THIS IS
THE NATURE ABOUT GOVERNMENT AND
ATTITUDES WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
FACING AND WHAT HAS BEEN
CONTROLLING THE COUNTRY.
>> Will: I TOTALLY AGREE IT'S A
STARTING POINT HAD WHICH WE MAY
SEE GROW IN THE COMING DAYS.
BECAUSE ELON MUSK SEEMS TO BE
TEASING THE IDEA THAT THE NEXT
REVELATIONS TWITTER FILES IS THE
EXTENT THEY WENT TO CONTROL OUR
MINDS WHEN IT CAME TO COVID.
HE TWEETED THE FOLLOWING MY
PRONOUNCE ARE "PROSECUTE/FAUCI.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW THIS HE
WENT ON STAGE DAVE CHAPELLE
CONCERT AND BOOED IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
THE ATLANTIC WROTE THIS THE
TWEET IS A CRUEL AND SENSELESS
PLAY ON PRONOUNS RIGHTS TOWARDS
FLOWN FAUCI THAT ACTUALLY SAID,
TAMMY, THIS WAS AN OFFENSE
AGAINST FAUCI AND, BY THE WAY,
DANGEROUS TOWARDS THE TRANS.
>> THAT'S IT.
EVERYTHING IS A DANGER.
CONDITIONING PEOPLE INTO FEAR.
WRITING A BOOK HOW FEAR IS USED
TO CONTROL SOCIETY.
ALL OF THIS MOVES INTO FEAR.
MAKING PEOPLE WHO ARE LIBERALS
FEARFUL.
SAYING EVERYTHING IS A DANGER.
MAKING CONSERVATIVES AND OTHERS
WHO DON'T CONFORM TO FEEL LIKE
I'M A DANGER TO SOCIETY, IT'S
OBSCENE, IT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
THOSE ACCUSATIONS AGAINST MUSK
ARE FALSE.
THEY ARE LIES BUT THIS IS WHERE
YOU SEE WHAT THEY FALL BACK ON
THE TRAINING THEY HAVE BEEN
TRAINING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND OF ALL PEOPLE WHO SHOULD NOT
WANT TO BE TRAINED, BEHAVE IN A
CERTAIN WAY, IT SHOULD BE THE
LEFT, THERE'S A REASON I WAS ON
THE LEFT.
IT USED TO BE ABOUT REAL
PERSONAL FREEDOM.
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
WANTING GOVERNMENT OUT OF OUR
LIVES.
AND, YET, NOW THIS IS WHAT WE
HAVE GOT.
>> Will: YEAH.
TRAINING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.